le but en or face au paraguay
l'exploit de laurent blanc durant la
complément de 1998 comme du sud laurent
blanc né à alès est un pur produit de la
formation à la française
capitaine de montpellier le club de son
coeur avec lequel il remporte son
premier trophée la coupe de france en
1992 il entamera ensuite un todorov un
passage à naples puis retour en france
c'est à auxerre qu'il se relance il
remporte le doublé coupe-championnat
1996 après un bref séjour à barcelone il
rejoint marseille le club de ses rêves
où il héritera du soudan le président
l'an en bleu c'est d'avoir la coupe du
monde 1998
son but en or et son expulsion
injustifiée en demi finale face à la
croatie sans plus grand regret nous ne
disputera pas la finale de la coupe du
monde mais fera le tour d'honneur avec
ses camarades et sera de la prête
avec l'équipe de france il remportera
l'euro 2000 laurent blanc est comblée
j'ai la chance de côtoyer l'équipe de
france très tôt d'avoir énormément de
déception au départ et après d'avoir
énormément de satisfaction comme jeudi
l'équipe de france a été pour moi ma
maîtresse durant toute ma carrière
sportive
mais l'image de la victoire des bleus et
ce baiser de laurent blanc sur le crâne
de fabien barthez c'est que je me laisse
tomber les plugins et donc ça dure et
c'est par mois +23 rendez vous saleh
sommes robidog on ne verra plus une
élégante silhouette sur les terrains
mais nul doute que le président sera
présent dans les coulisses